Six months ago I didn't know to bike, but tomorrow I'm cycling in a 100 mile bike race.
I've got three goals for this race.
Number one, have a good time.
Number two, practice fueling for my Ironman 70.3.
And third...
Finish the race.
I just got a text message from a person who's also doing this race that I just got introduced to.
And he's like, you've probably got all of your carbs and everything lined out for tomorrow.
Guys, I don't have anything lined up.
I brought solely fruit jerky and like some random carbohydrates that I had in my cabinet.
Got three bagels.
Two 84 gram things of honey.
Then I have this from running my marathon in 2024, October.
I actually have a lot of these.
I have brought like 10 of them.
And then I have this little rice crispy treat.
And then I have these bars.
And that's what I thought with me.
I thought this was gonna be just like a 100 mile run.
Yay!
And now I'm like... I've got a lot of people who are training for a full Iron Man and they do like, let's go for 100 mile bike ride.
And I'm like, I can do that.
I've done 50 before.
That's fine.
But this... this... I've never done this before.
It's an adventure.
You just have to look at it like that.
You know?
This is gonna be between 8 and 10 hours of adventure.
Oh man.
Ready or not?
It's time to do this.
Good morning.
I'm gonna prep my bottles.
I've got two things in place.
We won't catch me buying this in any other situation.
Oh my gosh, first ever bike race is a century ride.
Guys, who would have thought I'd be here six months later, right in a century?
Oh, can you tell?
I did in fact take free work out this morning.
There's a theme, guys.
There's a theme.
Hey, it's pitch black outside.
I'm putting sexy cams.
Feels a little wrong.
Look at these tires.
Definitely some more air.
That looks like a bike.
I can go up hills right there.
Yeah.
Yeah, it does.
Look at those gears.
Especially while using both gears, you know?
Yeah.
But when I fell over, it like pushed both of them.
And I'm like, wait a minute.
What does that do?
Like pushing both of them?
Is that different?
So I tried it.
It's different.
I have learned.
I've learned.
15 curbs every 15 minutes.
I'm gonna do one, two, three, four.
I'll pack these in here.
This is the most weird.
Here's what I put in the back of this thing.
Natalie goes, do you have your shoes?
And I'm like, I might need those.
I might need my shoes.
And also my helmet and my sunglasses.
I have this motto that I do especially when I'm swimming.
Yes, you can.
Yes, you can with like different strokes.
And I have a feeling that I'm gonna be setting out a lot today.
I got my bike out of here and felt like the tires were like so low.
We were searching for
At the start line, I was able to meet up with Josh, who was the one giving me advice last night.
His dad were doing the 65 mile bike race and so for the first 20 miles I stuck with them and their group.
Feeling pretty good.
My legs are kind of hurting.
And I think this is the fastest I've ever done 20 miles.
But I found some friends.
I think we're coming up on the first red stop now.
How does it feel so far?
It's been good.
I've been cycling with Josh and his dad and their friends.
So that's been really nice.
They've been giving me lots of tips.
What have you been talking about?
Um, drafting.
Get in here, Josh.
She's just been killing it.
She literally pulled us the entire way as you say.
Yeah, alright, yeah, alright.
I'm like done already.
She's leaving the pack.
And we're about to fuel up.
Yes.
We're about to fuel up.
Wait, are you the girl in Instagram?
Yes!
Sorry, what's your name?
How's your mind?
How are you?
Oh, I'm doing great.
I'm doing great.
It's so fun.
I'm having fun.
I feel like I'm feeling okay.
It was hard for me on the bike to fuel.
The heart rate is currently 119.
So that tells you how high it's been.
Are you ready?
I think so.
No.
I love you guys.
We're pretty much famous right now.
We're gonna be on YouTube.
You wanna be on YouTube?
Okay, let's do it.
Now I may be riding 100 miles today, but I've been wearing my
I'm eating these hills for breakfast.
And I'm having the best...
Wearing my whoop helps me understand when it's time to push myself, when I'm in the green, and then also when it's time to rest and recover.
It gives me all the data and information to approach my body, training, and performance with understanding.
One of my new favorite features of whoop is that it now works with the Natural Cycles app.
So for all my ladies who are looking to track their cycles, whoop is the place to do it.
If you'd like to give whoop a try, you can click the link in my description or go to join.whoop.com slash Riley Reel to get a one month free trial of whoop and a 5.0 band for free.
Got some big hills coming up!
Do it.
I just made it to the top of one of the red forts.
We got another one up there.
You'll make it.
I started crying.
Seems like it's straight up.
Just keep going.
And when you think you're at the top, almost to the top, there's a little bit more to go.
Okay.
Riley real drinking soda.
Full second.
Big cookies.
I found a friend.
Or like he found me.
Just hit 56 miles.
This is the distance for my half-iron man.
And I feel like rain!
Let's go!
This is amazing.
Look where this ever ridden.
Yes.
And I'm so proud of myself.
And I'm kind of hurting, but it's okay.
I'm happy.
After being told by everybody who runs this race that the second hill climb is really difficult, I was getting scared.
I'm about to start the hill climb.
I can do this.
Yes I can.
Yes I can do it.
Let's do it.
I started crying on the way up that hill.
It was really hard.
But I can do this.
I can do it.
I am capable.
Yes, I can.
I can do this.
I am really hungry, and I don't have any more fade, and I barely have any water, so I'm just trying to take it easy, keep moving, and then I can refuel when I get to the next rest stop.
Can't believe I made it!
You cried.
Yeah, is there blood yet?
No.
Thankfully, not gonna... Just sweat and tears.
Big fish girl.
Thank you guys so much.
Have a good ride.
Thank you.
My spirits are raised.
Your legs feeling better?
Still hurting?
It's gonna hurt.
It feels better than when I first got off, but it's gonna hurt as soon as I sit down because it's literally like where my butt cheek sits on the seat.
It's like super sore.
I will see you at the finish line.
Mile 95!
Woo!
Feeling pretty good.
Look at that!
100!
I did it!
What a fun adventure that race was.
And honestly, I think the biggest thing that I took from this experience is how grateful I am for my body.
How grateful I am for a capable body.
I don't know if you've seen my YouTube short about this or not, but I haven't had a period for about a year, and that's something that I've been working on getting back.
And as part of that process, I have to eat a lot of food in a surplus.
Yada yada yada.
I'm making a whole video about it, but I've been really having a hard time with that lately and I feel like doing this challenge just put things back into perspective for me and reminded me that my body is capable and...
How wonderful that is and how grateful I should be for it.
Training for things and doing races teaches me so many wonderful lessons.
And this one definitely did that and I'm grateful for it.
I loved getting to race with other people and have that community aspect of it.
Share my enjoyment and love of cycling with other people because I haven't really done that since I started.
The goal of this life is to learn and to grow and to progress.
And oftentimes that comes through challenges, whether it's challenges that you give yourself or challenges that come as a result of living in this world.
It's so good for us.
They help us to become.
I hope you guys enjoyed this video.
I hope it reminded you, like it reminded me, that you are capable, that you can do hard things, and that you can become the person you want to be.
And I'm grateful for the opportunity to participate in things like this and to challenge myself in these ways.
And I encourage you To do the same.
Also, I just recently got reached out to about an opportunity to run one of my bucket list races this fall.
I'm going to.
And it's gonna be... hard.
But it's also gonna be really fun and I'm excited to bring you guys along.
Thank you so much for watching.
I'm so grateful to have you here.
I love you and I will see you in my next video.
Bye guys!